Yeah.
So,
so,
okay,
so there is something we could talk about for a minute because you know,
there's,
uh,
there's political,
what do you call rumblings about the fact that I think a lot of this is
generated by the radical left types,
particularly on the campuses,
but the system is rigged and that it's an oppressive patriarchy.
And that the reason that people are at the top is because they played power
games.
And you know,
it's this,
my sense is that the control is that we're,
we're ethnic or racial or gender groups and we're competing in the Marxists
manner and those who win have one because of oppression.
But I know the literature on the relationship between individuals,
individual differences and longterm life success in the Western world and the
literature is actually very clear.
So intelligence seems to account for about 20% of the variants in longterm life
success.
And then trait conscientiousness accounts for perhaps another,
maybe 10 to 15%.
And then there's smaller contributions of emotional stability,
um,
and also have trait openness,
which seems to be a good predictor of entrepreneurial ability.
So it looks like in the West that you can attribute about 40 to 50% of the
variants.
Maybe that's a little high,
but it's,
it's not,
it's not a radical over estimate to the sorts of individual differences that are
associated with productivity because increases in Iq hierarchy you at higher
conscientiousness definitely make people more productive.
It seems to me that you can use that as an index of the,
um,
of the,
of the genuinely meritocratic nature of a culture and also as an index of its
willingness to engage in fair play because you'd expect if it,
if your culture is aimed at productivity and it turns out that those are the
most PR and it turns out that the most productive people are in fact
differentially rewarded.
That seems to me to be a reasonable index of the success of this society now
that that is still leaves 50 to 60% of the variance on explained.
And so you can,
in there you could include racism and prejudice and the tyranny of the system
and blind luck can physical health and all of the arbitrary and random events
that make up that determined whether someone is successful or fails in life.
But it does seem to me to provide a metric saying that not only is our society
crazily productive and reasonably and reasonably good at district distributing
the spoils,
even though there's still some inequality,
but a fair bit of inequality is actually generated as a consequence of
differences in genuine productivity that seem reasonable to you.
Yeah,
maybe it ought to be obvious and,
but now,
except for the fact that in a lot of intellectual life,
the assumption is that the correlation between a psychological traits and
success is zero.
So the fact that it's,
you know,
let's say it's 40%,
I think it says 33% I bet a lot higher than in most people are willing to
acknowledge.
And what you said is exactly right.
That leaves more than half of the variance not to be correlating that with
individual differences.
And of course,
uh,
various inequities could go into that,
that got 50 or 60%.
And uh,
there's no,
they're not mutually
I,
it seems hard.
Uh,
we,
we know that there's a lot of gaming of the system particularly yeah.
United States by,
by the wealthy.
Uh,
and that should obviously be eliminated.
It's not,
not fair.
It's not.
If we could also ask another question is whether the rewards that go to the
talented are necessarily in sectors that lead to what we might call a
productivity in the sense of,
of,
um,
increasing societal wealth.
And an argument can be made that there's some misallocation of intellectual
resources that we have,
uh,
that the,
economy,
uh,
is,
to,
to driven by,
by finance that the,
uh,
there are too many lawsuits.
Legal system is each other.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
our estimated by intellectuals,
this does still leave a,
a,
a place for criticizing a number of the,
uh,
the reason which our economy is set up.
There's always scope for improvement.
Yes.
And we were talking about why despite the fact that a fair bit of the variance
or a third to half of the variance in,
in life success is taken up by let's say,
individual attributes,
there's still room for a systemic critique that's valid.
Yeah.
One of the pathologies of intellectual life that I wrote about it in the blank
slate about denial of human nature was that,
uh,
the in,
in polite company and the intellectual circles,
the amount of light success determined by a inherent and largely heritable
psychological traits has to be zero.
I mean that just the,
the,
the only acceptable position.
And you,
and I know it's not zero.
Well,
so let me interject for one second.
I'm also,
there's a fairness element there.
But the other thing is,
it seems to me that that's extraordinary self serving of people too.
Because you know,
if you get together with a group of Harvard professors,
for example,
um,
it's pretty obvious that their innate intelligence is one of the factors that
determine their success.
And to deny the fact that heritable differences make a difference means perhaps
to act as an Avatar of a social justice orientation,
but equally to deny the role of,
of the benefits of Champs in your own success and to their,
for lack a certain degree of humility that you might otherwise be required to
have.
So it's not all,
and I'm not claiming that you were implying this at all,
but it's not all in the service of higher social ideals that people denied they,
the contribution of,
of heritable components,
for example,
the birth laundry.
So,
okay.
Okay.
Whoops.
We just,
okay.
I unfortunately the video just froze and after you said,
I'm not saying you claimed this,
uh,
you suddenly froze on the screen.
We're not saying you're claiming this.
Sure.
Well,
it's just,
it seems self serving for people who are particularly bright,
for example,
to not be grateful for the fact that they won the genetic lottery in that in
that manner and insufficiently humble,
um,
to not know what the role of that arbitrary chance in determining their success.
I mean it's not like they don't deserve their success because of that,
but claiming a certain degree of biological determinism,
it doesn't necessarily make you a bad person even though it can be read that way
because it makes you very sensitive to your own good fortune if you,
if you think it through carefully.
Oh absolutely.
In fact,
successful people are the winners of at least three lotteries.
One of them that you mentioned,
of course it's the genetic lottery lottery.
The fact that does that some people were born with greater intelligence and
conscientiousness and openness to experience.
Another is that there's a a second lottery in a human development that is not
strictly genetic,
but it is in a sense constitutional or developmental.
The fact that I might consider this one of the most profound discoveries in the
history of psychology,
that correlation is between identical twins reared together,
are generally on the order of 0.5.
Uh,
and they share not only their genome,
but,
uh,
the vast amount of their environments that their parents,
their neighborhoods,
they're older sibs.
They're younger sibs,
the number of books in the house,
number of guns in the house,
number of TVs in the house,
yet they're not indistinguishable.
A identical twins are a correlate quite highly,
but no one near perfectly,
which means that there is a second lottery that has to do either with just the
way the,
the brain,
uh,
congeals during development,
which can't be specified down to the last synapse by the genes.
Uh,
and perhaps by chance life events,
which might leave unpredictable traces that we can't add a documenter or
systematically understand.
And then of course,
there's the third lottery of,
uh,
what happens to you in your profession.
Did you bet on the right sector?
Did you happen to have a good relationship with the boss?
Numerous.
Right?
It's a matter of being in the right place at the right time,
the right time.
So all that having been said,
um,
and,
and you're,
you're absolutely right.
We have to acknowledge the none zero role of,
uh,
of hereditary can permit and talent the one zero role of chance.
And that still leaves a big chunk of the variance that could be due to systemic
features of the system that perhaps ought to be changed.
There's just no doubt that the wealthy game,
the system,
particularly in the United States in a number of ways that don't work to,
to the,
the benefit of society at large.
There are also aspects of the system that are perhaps fair but irrational.
The fact that so much of our intellectual talent now gets sucked into finance.
Now of course we do need a financial sector and it's good that they're smart
people in it,
but having a lot of our brain power devoted to figuring out how to act on
financial information,
it Microsoft microsecond faster than ones competitors is probably not the best
use of our society's intellectual capital.
Likewise,
a lot of,
there's no doubt that we have far too much brain power invested in,
in the the legal system in a corporation suing each other,
patent trolling and another not so productive uses.
Yeah.
Well the funny thing is too,
there's an,
there's a new routing in erotic or amount of pathology in,
in a system in some sense.
I mean one of the things that struck me quite hard for example is that if you
look at the creativity curves across the lifespan,
they matched the criminality curves almost perfectly.
And one of the things that made me think when I was doing that research was so
that as young men become more antisocial,
they also become more creative.
Even though those things might not be correlated,
but they do map on top of one another and we're sticking in a society like the
United States,
which has a fair degree of criminality but also a fair degree of creativity.
We have no idea how loose the system has to be so that malfeasance can thrive so
that it can also be simultaneously loose enough so that creativity can thrive.
Right.
Because you might think if you were optimistic that you can tighten up the
system and get rid of the criminal behavior without adding a totalitarian layer
to this system that would also simultaneously demolish,
you know,
individual variability and creativity.
We just,
our models just aren't sophisticated enough to tease such things apart,
you know.
Well,
they,
I,
I'm not so sure there.
I do agree with you that there's a certain amount of,
uh,
risk taking or young men on the bake that might underlie both criminality and,
productive creativity.
But,
uh,
over the course of history,
I think one of the accomplishments of civilization and indeed of,
uh,
of enlightenment driven progress is that we have managed to tease them apart.
Just two examples are the fact that the rate of homicide punished by a factor of
about 35 from the Middle Ages to the 20th century and that,
and that includes the scientific revolution,
the Industrial Revolution,
and the enlightenment to all of the events of the 20th century.
So justice people were not stabbing each other.
So if we're in salts,
they were also coming up with the theory of evolution than the atomic theory of
matter.
And then again,
the 1990s when the rate of violent crime in the United States fell by half,
and they were also declines in Canada,
Britain,
other western countries.
This certainly was not a time of economic stagnation or tech.
No,
no.
Fair enough.
I guess then the question starts to become is how in the world did those things
get teased apart so that we are able to regulate anti social behavior without
simultaneously making things,
um,
excessively rigid,
unregulated totalitarian.
We managed it.
Maybe it's part of that same incremental process that you detailed out at the
beginning of our talk.